hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
some big thor ragnarok news and black
panther cate blanchett might be playing
a big villain for thor ragnarok and ryan
coogler the guy who directed the Creed
movie is going to be directing black
panther
so Thor's stuff first Cate Blanchet
there's two big possibilities about
which villains she's playing and the
reason people think she's playing a
villain now is because Mark Ruffalo at
the Golden Globes was like I can't wait
to see her play a big bad so the Hulk is
out of the bag there are two big female
Thor related characters that she could
be playing there's enchantress big Loki
collaborator Tom Hiddleston has said he
would love to do in chanters at some
point and then the other one is an even
bigger character Halle she is the ruler
of the Asgardian afterlife which in the
Thor comics is a physical place that you
can travel to but it's kind of like a
different state of being so when you die
as an Asgardian is not like you're dead
forever
so he'll hgl the place that she rules
over is a place that you can travel out
of you can claw your way back to life
but she has absolute power in her realm
so even though she's not as big of a
character say Thanos I would say she is
Thanos level in comparison to the other
villains that they could pick from so
that's kind of why I'm hoping Cate
Blanchett's playing in chant hrus it'd
be a little more relatable a little bit
easier to use her with other characters
because it's really hard to give
characters convincing ways to fight big
bads on the level of Thanos like when
you use Thanos he's just he's so
powerful that it's hilarious when other
people try to fight him enchantress and
halat are just the most likely
candidates and what they might end up
doing if she does end up being Halle is
they might proxy her for death in the
Marvel Universe because she kind of
represents death in an Asgardian way if
you don't know anything about the
Infinity Gauntlet or the infinity quest
Thanos is in love with death in order to
win her affections he assembles the
Infinity Gauntlet snaps his fingers and
kills 50% of all life in the universe
instantly the twist is is that death
doesn't want to have anything to do with
them so you know Thanos sad can't win
her affection no matter how many people
he destroys but even though Marvel is
doing a version of this for infinity war
you know Thanos assembles the Infinity
Gauntlet tries to destroy the universe
everyone else in the Marvel Universe has
to team up to stop him that doesn't mean
they're not going to change a whole
bunch of story elements they
they haven't even gotten to the cosmic
idea of death yet so that's why I think
you know Cate Blanchet if she's playing
the holo character could be a proxy for
that they've gotten pretty weird but you
guys can let me know in the comments who
do you think the Cate Blanchett is
playing in a more relatable and chant
restrictor much more on the power level
with most of the big characters or Halle
an even bigger character Thanos level
character now if you've read the comics
there are two different versions of
enchantress there's the original amaura
and then there's another version of The
Enchantress that Loki created later
himself as a tool of chaos my guess is
if they go with The Enchantress
character that they would choose the
original enchantress amaura she chooses
a little bit more grand in the classic
comics as much as she could be a big bad
I'm also expecting to see some version
of Fire Lord circa just because he's so
important to the idea of Ragnarok in the
Marvel Universe I think I've said in my
previous tour videos but the Ragnarok
that thor ragnarok implies is the Jack
Kirby version of Ragnarok not the Civil
War clone which is also called Ragnarok
the idea behind the Jack Kirby Ragnarok
is that he was basically reinvigorating
the Thor comics he killing off a bunch
of characters destroying Asgard and then
a new Asgard would be reborn in its
ashes
there's even reports because Jack Kirby
was working on his fourth world comics
at the time that he intended the new
gods to replace the Asgardian gods but
then he ended up moving to DC so he did
fourth world New Gods with DC and Marvel
just rebooted all the normal Thor
characters in the context of the movies
most of that still works pretty well I
mean they kind of destroyed Asgard and
Thor the dark world but imagine it being
destroyed in a really big cosmic way
they said that Thanos isn't going to be
a big part of guardians of the galaxy -
and that's one of the last films before
Avengers infinity war but as far as I
know thor ragnarok the movie is going to
be relatively self-contained to those
characters with the addition of the Hulk
Hulk is definitely going to be part of
Ragnarok moving on to black panther news
this is actually really exciting if you
don't know who Ryan Coogler is he's
going to be directing Black Panther but
he directed the Creed movie which is a
rocky sequel of sorts but it feels so
fresh and amazing a spy being I think
it's the seventh rocky film I think
there are seven rocky films now with
Creed and they're doing a sequel to
Creed but now that ryan coogler signed
onto black panther he's not going to be
doing it I'm sure it'll still be fun I'm
just I'm not super invested with the
rocky franchise as much as I am with the
Marvel films so really I feel
this is the best possible thing that
could have happened to the Black Panther
movie next to Chadwick Boseman being
cast he's going to be an awesome Black
Panther right now they're working on
casting the rest of the film we're gonna
see some of Wakanda during Captain
America Civil War but it's going to be
the job of Black Panthers movie to flesh
that out we know about vibranium we know
who Black Panther is we're going to see
him in Captain America Civil War so you
have an intro to the character but you
won't learn a whole lot about the
culture of Wakanda and where they fit in
the world
technically Black Panther is one of the
richest people in the Marvel Universe
because vibranium is so precious he's
way richer than Tony Stark
so without turning it into too much of a
geopolitical thriller the Black Panther
movie you know really has to tell the
story of this person who has to take the
throne after his father is killed and
learned how to rule a nation and be a
member of the Avengers in this larger
context of the Marvel Universe we don't
know exactly what the storyline is going
to be but I'm assuming it's going to be
a version of the origin story and
they're going to tell it in a similar
way to the way Doctor Strange is
handling the Doctor Strange origin story
meaning it's not going to be super
linear there's going to be a lot of
flashbacks but we might start the movie
in present-day especially because we're
already going to see what he looks like
in the costume so he'll have already
become Black Panther when we see him for
the first time usually any first movie
that a superhero gets is pretty straight
forward this is who this person is this
is how they got there this is where
they're headed next if you don't know
anything about Black Panther and you
want to read one of his origin story
comics they did this miniseries I think
it was around 2004 is intended to be a
really easy read so check it out there's
a little bit of talk about spider-man
Captain America Civil War stuff in that
there's supposed to be some sort of
hoodie revealed like an actual hoodie
that you wear that's going to reveal
what spider-man's costume is going to
look like I don't know if that's true
but it's supposed to happen on the 15th
so if it happens we can totally talk
about it if not don't worry about it
the real talk about an infinity war now
is how many characters are going to be
in it the Russos are teasing that it's
going to be more than 60 characters it's
going to be crazy which I don't think is
a strike in its favor having more
characters doesn't necessarily make a
movie better but they weren't trying to
say that they were just saying that
there's going to be a lot of people in
it but that is how you fit in the
Netflix characters and other minor
characters from the TV shows you know
people that you would want to see in the
movies are not necessarily big enough
characters to merit big screen time
I'm actually kind of blown away that
there's so much movie stuff happening
right now usually January is this dead
period but if you guys haven't seen it
while you wait for my Star Wars video
you can click here for all my Star Wars
Easter eggs I've done about three Star
Wars Easter Egg videos and you can click
here to learn all about Spider Man and
Captain America Civil War thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you